[Musique]
[Rires]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de mode d'emploi consacré aux
métiers du numérique et plus précisément
de la cybersécurité tout de suite le
sommaire nous prendront la direction de
montigny le bretonneux où sont installés
les locaux de l'afnic est la seule
entité en france qui gère et sécurise
les noms de domaine en point fr focus
sur le métier d'administrateur réseau
ayo tim hecker ou encore data security
lpr ces formations proposées par pop
school ont été labellisée école
numérique par saint quentin en yvelines
baptiste dufour chargé de communication
nous en dira plus
attrape le lns le laboratoire national
de métrologie et d'essai est à la
recherche d'eau dieter en cybersécurité
plus de détails dans ce rendez vous
consacré aux entreprises du territoire
qui recrutent
saviez vous que les sites internet en
point fr un essai dans les yvelines et
plus précisément à montigny le
bretonneux elle ces noms de domaine sont
gérés mais aussi sécurisé par une
association l'association s'appelle
l'afnic
reportage avec ces images signées
patrick jacques de dixmude
nous sommes à montigny le bretonneux
c'est ici que sont installés les locaux
de l'afnic l'afnic
c'est une association mandatée par
l'état chargé de gérer les noms de
domaine français comme le point fr pour
la france ou encore le point et reprend
la réunion 80 personnes travaillent
qu'ici
[Musique]
ça consiste en quoi finalement gérer un
nom de domaine on s'assure en fait c'est
l'équivalent d'une poste qu'on s'assure
que où que vous soyez dans le monde
vous pouvez accéder ces sites
wii points sncf par exemple ou un point
leclerc trouver le magasin de mamie qui
à côté qui en bretagne par exemple un
exemple
ben vous pouvez le trouver même si vous
êtes aux états unis a trouvé que le
magasin il est ce qu'il est toujours
ouvert ou pas at-elle à quelle heure ils
ouvrent etc ou gérer ce nom de domaine
l'afnic propose également d'autres
services
on essaie de faire développer au niveau
des pme et des tpe dont on a tout un
travail en cours où on va
anicet style far qui vise à faire
développer la transformation numérique
de toutes ces entreprises qui
aujourd'hui n'ont pas ou ne pense pas
aller sur le web pour se faire connaître
et pour se faire connaître justement on
a des initiatives qui sont avec eux
réussir avec réussir leur en point fr et
on a aussi des sites d'autodiagnostic
c'est à dire que les boîtes vont faire
des tests pour voir comment ils sont et
ce qu'ils maîtrisent bien leur leur
identité numérique et il passe sa part
réussir avec le web
[Musique]
d
gabriel bonjour bonjour vous êtes
administrateur réseau ici au sein de
l'afi nick alors on parlera dans
quelques instants évidemment de votre
vos missions quotidiennes avance que
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus sur sur
vous sur votre parcours
oui bien sûr alors j'ai commencé par de
faire une école d'ingénieurs en
informatique donc 3 en classe prépa
intégrée puis deux ans de spécialisation
j'ai pas commencé par faire du réseau à
proprement parler aux du système j'ai
commencé par faire de la programmation
et puis j'ai fini grâce à des stages et
une alternance par m'orienter dans le
réseau et donc le métier
d'administrateur réseau s'est
majoritairement faire du monitoring donc
surveiller l'ensemble de
l'infrastructure intervenir rapidement
en cas d'incidents notamment dans le
cadre de l'astreinte donc h/24 et
déployer des nouveaux équipements venir
en aide aux utilisateurs
alors est ce qu'il ya des difficultés
dans ce métier pour rencontrer
quotidiennement
tout à fait
je dirais que la principale difficulté
c'est d'intervenir à l'incident autant
lorsqu'on est dans l'open space
on est un peu porté par le groupe dès
qu'un incident on est on est plutôt
solidaires quand vous parlez d'incidents
c'est quoi par exemple par exemple
l'accès l'accès au site web cncf via nos
services n'est plus accessible
on va devoir investiguer pour voir à
quel niveau
seul le problème s'est produit c'est à
dire soit c'est sur nos auteurs c'est
sur nos serveurs et donc intervenir en
fonction c'est à dire apporter un
apporté une correction redémarrer
éventuellement un service ou au pire des
cas redémarre ali sarwar fait cette
notion de challenge c'est ça qui vous
plaît dans ce métier
oui et pas seulement il ya aussi le fait
qu'à l'avenir on puisse aussi avoir on
n'est pas scindé dans un seul corps de
métier en a plusieurs
je suis spécialisé dans le réseau mais
je fais aussi du dns de la
virtualisation du système de la bd etc
et du coup c'est aussi pouvoir devenir
un peu experts dans tous ces domaines
qui inquiète vraiment intéressante
aujourd'hui 44 % des noms de domaine en
france sont en point comme 36 % le sont
en point fr un chiffre que l'afnic tente
à promouvoir pour qu'ils augmentent dans
les prochaines années et pour rendre
encore plus accessible ces métiers du
numérique et de la cybersécurité pour
répondre également aux attentes des
entreprises
saint quentin en yvelines a créé il ya
quelques mois son label école du
numérique à certaines formations sont
déjà ouvertes d'autres le seront à la
rentrée
c'est le cas notamment de pop cool les
images sont signés et mélanie poquet et
car la vie jean baptiste dufour bonjour
bonjour vous êtes chargé de
communication pour pop school alors pour
commencer est ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter votre organisme depuis quand
existe et il a bien sûr alors pop school
c'est un organisme de formation qui est
spécialisée dans les métiers émergent du
numérique on existe depuis 2015 dans les
rues de france un autre établissement
history c'était à valenciennes où depuis
nous avons formé près dé 200 apprenants
depuis on a ouvert de nouveaux
établissements à lens à saint quentin
dans l'aisne à maubeuge et enfin nous
arrivons ici à 50 ans mais voilà en
octobre prochain il y aura donc deux
formations labellisées sky écoles
numériques disponibles alors une
formation d'al houthi haïti makers
désolé pour mon anglais est une
formation de data security elle porte
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter
chacune de ces formations
bien sûr à loreley au tim hecker c'est
une formation de six mois quatre mois de
cours puis deux mois de stage lie outil
qu'est ce que c'est la yaute si on en
parle de plus en plus normalement dans
la santé dans la smart cities dans
l'agriculture connectés sont que des
exemples
si on prend l'exemple par exemple du
parking connectés de plus en plus on
voit ces parkings ou en fait on peut
voir à distance des places qui sont
disponibles en fait ce sont des systèmes
embarqués
les personnes qui les intégreront
nos formations la formation d'ailleurs
tim hecker par exemple travailleront sur
ce genre de dispositif à saint quentin
dans l'aisne on a déjà fait une première
promotion puisaye travaillé par contre
sur une station météo connecter aussi
des personnes qui vont prototype et
créer des objets connectés en fait pour
l'industrie ou bien encore pour de
nombreux domaines la formation elle data
security halper sait plus sur une
formation cybersécurité on peut dire ça
le but de cette formation c'est de faire
des professionnels de la sécurité des
parisiens des personnes qui sont
capables de sécuriser des rencontres des
parcs informatiques alors les critères
pour suivre ces formations est ce qu'il
faut avoir de l'expérience dans ces
domaines à elle qu'il faut avoir un
diplôme en particulier alors toutes les
formations comme ce cours s'adresse en
fait à tout le monde
il n'y a pas de critère d'âge le seul
critère qu'il ya c'est un critère de
motivation il faut juste être motivé
pour intégrer une formation certes après
lors du dossier d'inscription qui se
trouvent en ligne nous demandons en fait
ça dépend ce soit pour l'information des
traces jusqu'à la peur ou bien
informations ariotti de passer des tests
qui permettent en fait simplement du
juge la motivation du candidat
est-ce qu'il faut avoir des notions
d'anglais quand même plus confiant
ce travail en informatique est ce qu'il
faut quand même avoir des notions
d'anglais alors il ya des notions
d'anglais à avoir mais sont plus de
notions techniques donc en fait c'est un
niveau que tout le monde a très
rapidement au niveau du coût de cette
formation pour bien sa route alors la
formation est gratuite
grâce aux partenaires financeurs comme
50 ans l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines
la grande école numérique et voilà et
dernière question aux questions
pratiques déjà et ce qu'il reste encore
des places pour les formations qui
débute en octobre
il reste des places pour intégrer deux
formations
il suffit pour s'en sortir et d'aller
sur le site internet www.poweo.com de
s'inscrire sur de nourrir les dossiers
d'inscription en ligne de cliquer de
s'inscrire et provient de place par par
formation c'est 25 places par formation
sur une durée de trois ans mercy
bassiste et dufour en tout cas d'être
intervenu dans le cadre de cette
émission mode d'emploi je rappelle que
vous êtes chargé de communication tout
repos voilà vous en savez désormais plus
sur les métiers du numérique et de la
cyber sécurité
voici donc ce qu'il faut retenir pour
être administrateur réseau il faut être
titulaire au minimum d'un bac + 2
administration réseau pour les débutants
le salaire est en moyenne de 2000 euros
nets
l évolution possible dans ce métier être
responsable réseau et puis le petit plus
c'est bien savoir gérer le stress
si vous souhaitez devenir data sécurité
elle peur en français ça donne
assistant sécurisation de données il
faut suivre une formation dans ce
domaine ce que propose notamment comme
pop school ce que vous venez de voir
pour le salaire il faut compter environ
2500 euros nets pour les débutants
évolution possible directeur des
systèmes d'information enfin il faut
aimer le travail en équipe
à présent si vous êtes à la recherche
d'un emploi dans le domaine notamment de
la cybersécurité eh bien apprenez de
quoi noter le ellen et le laboratoire
national de métrologie et d'essais
recherche actuellement des auditeurs en
cyber sécurité ne l est ne est un
organisme public
un établissement public à caractère
industriel et commercial on propose de
haut niveau de la cybersécurité de
pouvoir qualifier d entreprises suivant
des référentiels annecy ou des
référentiels internationaux au type iso
27001 l'idéal c'est quand même d'avoir
quelques années d'expérience parce que
pour pouvoir auditer une entreprise il
est important de connaître
l'environnement industriel non
on est un peu obligé d'avoir au minimum
2 ans d'expérience mais sur des profils
spécifiques on peut les former au début
et puis après ça pour qu'il soit
rapidement opérationnel si vous
souhaitez postuler directement vous
pouvez envoyer un cv avec une lettre de
motivation à infos @ elle et ne point fr
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro s'était
d'ailleurs le dernier mode d'emploi de
la saison merci de l'avoir suivi vous
pouvez bien sûr retrouver ce mode
d'emploi mais aussi toutes les émissions
depuis à la rentrée sur notre site
internet www.tv5monde.com très bonnes
vacances et à bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]